* Leises Lachen *
Wäre das die Grössenordnung,
die Sie sich für Ihren Zirkus
vorstellen würden?
Ja, also ...
... vom Zelt her schon.
Und was die Wagen betrifft ...
Ja, ungefähr
in dieser Grössenordnung.
Wie heisst
denn eigentlich Ihr Zirkus?
Er würde Beat Breu heissen.
- Beat Breu?
Genau.
Er würde meinen Namen tragen,
da mich die Leute in der Schweiz
noch kennen.
Im Alter von 62 Jahren möchte
Beat Breu, einstiger Radsportheld,
zusammen mit seiner Frau Heidi
seinen Kindheitstraum verwirklichen
und einen Zirkus gründen.
Klein, aber fein soll er werden -
ähnlich wie der Circus Harlekin,
den sie besuchen, um zu sehen,
was die Konkurrenz so macht.
Es ist keine Boombranche, in die
sie einsteigen wollen, im Gegenteil.
Viele Zirkusunternehmen
kämpfen ums Überleben.
Es ist etwas windig.
- Ja.
Aber Breus Sehnsucht nach dem Zirkus-
leben ist stärker als alle Bedenken.
Ich muss etwas tun, wobei
ich eine gewisse Freiheit habe.
Warum? - Das liegt
einfach in meinem Naturell.
Ich könnte auch niemals
irgendwo in einer Fabrik
an einer Maschine arbeiten.
Ich bin lieber unterwegs.
Auch an den Velorennen
fuhr ich lieber von A nach B
als drei Wochen lang am selben Ort.
Das war langweilig. Ich ziehe
lieber etwas durch die Gegend.
* Drollige Musik *
Ich mache jetzt einfach mit, damit
er seinen Traum verwirklichen kann.
Ich müsste es nicht unbedingt ...
Also, nicht, dass es mich stören
würde. Dann würde ich Nein sagen.
Aber ich würde nicht sagen,
dass es auch mein Traum ist.
Vielleicht komme ich
irgendwann mit meinem Traum an.
Dann erschrickt er.
Ein Tanzkurs oder so.
- (Beat, abwehrend) Oh!
Das ist ein Albtraum und kein Traum.
* Er lacht. *
Vielleicht wird bis dahin
Walzer mit Rollator angeboten.
Ja.
Ja, ja. Nein.
Führten Sie denn schon mal
einen solchen Betrieb? - Nein.
Nein, ich führte
noch nie einen solchen Betrieb.
Aber wenn sie
die Büroarbeit übernimmt ...
Ich würde mir das
alleine nicht zumuten.
Das geht nicht.
Das kann ich auch nicht.
Ich bin eher
fürs Zirkusleben zuständig.
Sie übernimmt die Büroarbeit.
* Fröhliche Zirkusmusik *
Dem Alltagstrott entkommen
und in eine andere Welt eintauchen -
das werden die Menschen
auch in Zukunft wollen,
davon sind die Breus überzeugt.
Und genau das biete der Zirkus.
* Applaus *
* Ruhige Zirkusklänge *
Wir beginnen halt mit der Werbung.
Die Aufkleber und die Beschriftung
kommen vor den Fahrzeugen.
Anfang 2018 hatte Breu
einen ersten Anlauf genommen,
sich seinen Traum vom Zirkus
zu verwirklichen.
Beim Circus Royal führten er
und seine Frau das Bistro.
Nach einem Jahr trennte man sich
bereits wieder - in Unfrieden.
Nun wollen sie
einen eigenen Zirkus gründen.
Damit möchte Breu
zurück auf die Siegerstrasse -
dorthin, wo er als Sportler war.
Breu gehört zu den erfolgreichsten
Radrennfahrern der Schweiz.
Er gewann Klassiker
wie die sog. Züri Metzgete ...
* Hupen *
... und zweimal das Gesamtklassement
der Tour de Suisse.
(Sprecher) ... Beat Breu!
Aber Sie haben nur 6 Sek. Vorsprung
im Gesamtklassement.
Ja, das reicht. Schon 1 Sek. reicht.
* Das Publikum lacht. *
Auch auf der Bahn brillierte
der gelernte Briefträger.
Hopp, Beat, hopp!
Beat!
Sie sind
ein ziemlicher Fan von Beat Breu.
Was gefällt Ihnen an ihm?
- Dass er überall fährt:
querfeldein,
auf der Bahn, auf der Strasse.
Und er fährt gut.
(Sprecher) Peter Schneider.
In den 80er-Jahren eilte er von
Erfolg zu Erfolg und wurde gefeiert:
für seine sportlichen Leistungen
und für seine treffenden Sprüche.
Kurz: Breu war ein Star.
Ausrutscher waren selten.
Der "Bergfloh" war ein Sieger.
Auch bei der legendären Alpe-d'Huez-
Etappe an der Tour de France.
Ob das stimmt, können wir unseren
ersten Gast gleich selbst fragen.
Beat Breu wird bei der Auslosung im
Fussball später Glücksfee spielen.
Wenn man von Menschen umgeben ist,
ist man immer gefragt.
Das gehört einfach dazu.
Unser Gast heute Abend
ist der Bergfloh, Beat Breu.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Heute leben die Breus
in einem Wohnmobil,
parkiert auf dem Hof
eines befreundeten Bauern.
Was gibt es Leckeres?
Etwas, was Beat sehr mag:
Gehacktes und Hörnli.
* Beat lacht. *
Gell? - Das gab es am letzten
Velorennen auch, das ich fuhr.
Ja? Wegen dir?
- Ja.
Ach, was!
Sie veranstalteten in Altstätten
ja extra ein Rennen. - Ach so.
Abends im Saal
gab es Gehacktes und Hörnli.
1990 begann sein tiefer Fall. Davon
hat er sich bis heute nicht erholt.
Ein Telefonanruf stellte
mein Leben total auf den Kopf.
Welcher Anruf?
Als die Bank anrief und sagte,
es stimme etwas nicht mehr.
Ich stand
eigentlich auf einem Sockel.
Ich hatte gerade zum zweiten Mal
die Tour de Suisse gewonnen.
Mir ging es finanziell gut
und ich hatte eine Familie.
Ich hatte eigentlich alles.
Dieser Anruf änderte jedoch alles.
Über seinem Sechszimmerhaus
hoch über St. Gallen
mit Blick auf den Bodensee
zogen dunkle Wolken auf.
Die Idylle
mit seiner damaligen Frau Claudia
und den beiden Kindern
Marc und Denise wurde zerstört.
* Weinen des Babys *
Breus Bruder, ein Banker,
wurde verhaftet.
Er hatte seine Bank
mit cleveren Transaktionen
um über 60 Mio. erleichtert.
(Originalton) Und da beginnt
das Drama des Beat Breu.
Er hatte seinem Bruder
mehr als 500'000 Fr. überwiesen -
aus Erspartem und aus der Hypothek
auf seinem eigenen Haus.
Damit wurde er
Mitbesitzer von sechs Liegenschaften
im Gesamtwert von rund 12 Mio. Fr.
Beat Breu aber
möchte so schnell als möglich
aus diesem Besitz aussteigen,
um sein investiertes Geld
zurückzuerhalten.
Denn wegen der Solidarhaftung
riskiert er bei den gegenwärtig
tiefen Immobilienpreisen,
bei einem Verkauf
für viel Geld haften zu müssen.
Was würde mit Ihnen geschehen,
wenn ein Millionenschaden entstünde?
Also,
wenn ein Millionenschaden entsteht,
sind wir wie gesagt ruiniert.
Ich habe keine so grossen Reserven,
dass ich 1 Mio. decken könnte.
Wir können gut leben und hätten,
wenn dieser Fall nicht eingetreten
wäre, ein gutes Leben gehabt.
Wir hätten später nicht mehr
so viel arbeiten müssen
wie normale Bürger.
Wir hätten gut leben können.
Aber jetzt steht alles
auf wackligen Füssen.
Breus Hoffnung,
sich mit der Bank Leu,
welche die Häuseranteile
seines Bruders übernommen hatte,
gütlich einigen zu können,
war bald zerschlagen.
Breu war ruiniert.
Wenn mir jemand sagt,
er sei Bankdirektor ...
Vor einem Strassenkehrer
habe ich mehr Achtung.
Denn der tut etwas.
Der Bankdirektor tut nichts.
Mit Banken habe ich gar nichts mehr
am Hut, so wie die mit mir umgingen.
Und wie sie zuvor mit mir umgingen,
als ich
noch der grosse Velofahrer war ...
Wie war es damals?
Ich könnte Ihnen Dinge erzählen ...
Einer sagte mal zu mir:
"Herr Breu, wenn Sie mal Probleme
haben, kommen Sie nur zu mir."
Als ich Probleme hatte,
ging ich zu ihm.
Er kannte mich gar nicht mehr.
Er behandelte mich
wie den letzten Dreck.
Menschlich gesehen
sind das Schweine.
Sie nehmen grosse Mengen
und zerquetschen die Kleinen.
Ich habe absolut
keine Achtung vor jemandem mehr,
der auf einer Bank arbeitet.
(Mit Akzent) One, two, three, four.
Er brauchte dringend Geld,
um seine Schulden abzuzahlen.
Also fuhr er weiter Radrennen
und wurde zusätzlich Entertainer.
* Drollige elektronische Musik *
# I bi de Beat Breu.
# Er söll emol cho.
# Hei nomol, jetzt stohni do
und wett für eu eis singe.
# Ich chumm mer vor wie i de Schuel,
cha kein Piepser usebringe.
# Es isch mehr fast echli piinlech.
Es het doch gar kän Sinn.
# Scho d Lehreri hett behauptet,
dass i unmusikalisch bin.
Ich musste Dinge tun, die ich
normalerweise nicht getan hätte.
Ich hätte nie im Leben
eine Bühne betreten.
Aber die Leute sagten: "Das musst du
tun. Damit verdienst du gut."
"Wir kümmern uns schon um dich."
Das funktionierte auch,
das muss ich zugeben.
Aber nach sieben Jahren unterwegs,
nach etwa 700 Auftritten,
hatte ich einfach genug.
Mein Erfolg flachte auch ab.
Ich hatte
die Deutschschweiz abgeklappert.
Einige Firmen
sahen mich zweimal pro Woche.
Dann ist es
nicht mehr ganz so lustig.
Zudem hätte ich Neues lernen müssen.
Ich bin kein Mensch,
der unbedingt auftreten will.
Gardi Hutter sagte
vor einem Auftritt mal zu mir,
ihre schönsten 5 Min.
hätte sie vor einem Auftritt.
Ich sagte: "Meine schönsten 5 Min.
habe ich nach meinem Auftritt."
* Der Reporter lacht. *
Das ist nicht ganz dasselbe.
Für die Privatinsolvenz
war er zu stolz.
Also zahlte er damals
rund 20'000 Fr. pro Monat ab.
Ein Ende seiner Schulden
war trotzdem nicht in Sicht.
Wenn man auf einer Bühne steht,
geht es einem wie einem Clown.
Diesem ist auch nicht immer danach,
aber er muss einfach.
Den Zuschauern ist es eigentlich
egal, welche Probleme er hat.
Er ist dazu da,
um die Leute zu unterhalten.
Das ist nicht immer einfach,
aber das muss man während
dieser Zeit irgendwie ausblenden.
Es war schwierig.
Es war nicht leicht.
Bekamen Sie
in dieser Zeit Depressionen?
Ja, ich ...
Es gab Leute, die das behaupteten.
Aber ich empfand es selbst
nicht als Depressionen.
Aber ich war
einfach niedergeschlagen.
Zwischenzeitlich verschwand Breu
von der Bildfläche.
2001 tauchte er wieder auf.
Hallo. Hallo miteinander.
- Hallo miteinander.
Kommt ihr rein? Los.
Dies ist unser Mr Ed.
Auf ihm reite ich durch die Prärie
und in den Saloon hinein.
Er trat als Aushängeschild
eines Wildwest-Bordells
in Oberbüren/SG auf.
Zusammen
mit seiner damaligen Partnerin
betrieb er eine Art Sanitätsposten
im Notstandsgebiet männlicher Triebe.
Ich liege heute zum ersten Mal hier.
Es ist eine neue, feudale Matratze.
Hier drin lässt sich's leben.
Nach einem guten Jahr zog er sich
wieder aus dem Sex-Geschäft zurück.
Das grosse Geld, das er
und ein Investor im Hintergrund
sich erhofft hatten,
war ausgeblieben
und der einstige Sportheld
zur Witzfigur geworden.
* Schnelle Gitarrenklänge *
Mr Breu, please.
(Lispelnd, Ostschweizer Dialekt)
Ich glaube,
ich kaufe noch diesen Sattel hier.
Den kann ich nämlich gebrauchen,
jetzt da ich im Sattlergeschäft bin.
Ist das, ähm ...
Ist das ein Pferdehändler?
No, no, no, that's Beat Breu,
Switzerland's most famous pimp.
He has a fucking good job.
* Das Publikum lacht. *
Yes. Mr Breu, that's Sämi,
your new Verwaltungsrat.
Ah, freut mich.
Du dann machen wir doch gleich mal
so eine lustige Verwaltungsrats-
sitzung im rosa Salon,
zusammen mit meiner Frau
und Godi Schmutz, dem Schweinehund.
Wie heisst denn Ihre Firma?
- Longhorn-fick-dich.
Weisst du, wir haben
viele lange Hörner bei uns, Sämi.
Ach so, Sie ...
Sie handeln mit Rindern?
Haben Sie auch einen BSE-Fall?
Nein, BSE nicht.
Höchstens hin und wieder
mal ein bisschen Herpes.
Ich konnte gar
keinen normalen Job ausüben,
weil ich solchen Ärger
mit den Banken hatte
und meine Schulden abzahlen musste.
Mit einem normalen Einkommen
wäre das unmöglich gewesen.
Nun sagen einige Leute,
dass ich gescheitert bin
und die falschen Leute
getroffen habe.
Das ist schon klar, aber zu
diesem Zeitpunkt war das das Beste.
Breus öffentliche Auftritte
kippten zusehends
vom Komischen ins Tragische.
Im Alter von 49 Jahren
gab er ein Comeback als Steher
auf der offenen Rennbahn
in Zürich-Oerlikon.
Nach zwei erfolglosen Saisons
trat er wieder zurück.
Immer noch hoch verschuldet
und ohne Perspektive.
An seiner Seite inzwischen Heidi,
die seither mitansehen muss,
wie ihr Partner belächelt
oder gar ausgelacht wird.
Manchmal hat man
schon fast das Gefühl,
dass die Leute nur darauf warten,
um Beat wieder eins auszuwischen.
Das finde ich nicht ganz in Ordnung.
Man kann ja auch nicht
auf diese Leute losgehen und sagen:
"So, nun erzähl du mal, was du im
Leben schon Mieses geleistet hast!"
Aber, äh, aufregen oder so ...
Ich sage ihm jeweils:
"Vergiss es gleich wieder!"
Das ist das Beste. Es ist nicht
mehr wert, als es zu vergessen.
Im Moment
sind die Breus ohne Einkommen.
Sie leben von ihren Reserven.
Trotzdem seien sie
glücklich miteinander, sagen sie.
Ah, jetzt haben wir es.
- So.
So. Schön.
Jetzt werde ich wieder verlieren.
Zehn, 20.
20?
- Ja, wenigstens nicht doppelt.
Als wir uns kennenlernten
und miteinander ins Gespräch kamen,
passte es einfach von Anfang an.
Ich dachte:
"Wenn er meine Gefühle erwidert ..."
"... dann nehme ich ihn."
Ja.
- Was gefiel Ihnen denn an ihm?
Mir gefällt
natürlich seine Ehrlichkeit.
Ich mag diese Lügerei nicht.
Ich finde, wenn es Probleme gibt,
sollte man darüber reden können.
Man sollte keine Ausflüchte suchen.
Bei uns
klappte das eigentlich immer.
In welche Eigenschaft
Ihrer Frau verliebten Sie sich?
Uh!
In ihre Art und ...
Ach, das sind schwierige Fragen.
Ja. Sie ist eine Gute.
Sie tut viel und macht alles mit,
das ist wichtig.
* Rockmusik aus dem Radio *
Um seinen Traum vom Zirkus
zu verwirklichen,
hat Breu im Internet
ein Crowdfunding lanciert.
Mind. 50'000 Fr. will er so sammeln,
optimal wären 150'000.
Dafür rührt er nun
kräftig die Werbetrommel -
bis jetzt mit bescheidenem Erfolg:
Es sind erst gut 5'000 Fr.
zusammengekommen.
Denken Sie,
dass Sie noch Chancen haben?
Als ich das sah,
war ich auch etwas enttäuscht.
Ich dachte, es ginge schneller.
Breu hat ein ambivalentes Verhältnis
zu den Medien.
Am Anfang seiner Karriere
jubelten sie ihn hoch,
später war er ihr Fussabtreter.
Trotzdem liefert er sich
ihnen jetzt wieder aus.
Ich wünsche dir ganz viel Glück.
- Danke. - Ciao, Beat.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss, vielen Dank.
Gegen einen Journalisten
kann man nichts ausrichten.
Was soll ich dagegen tun, wenn es
bereits in der Zeitung steht?
Es richtigstellen?
- Das tat ich auch schon.
Danach wurde es noch schlimmer.
Nein, das ...
Dann kommt das Ganze wieder.
Jemand sagte mal:
"Sei einfach still.
Die Leute vergessen es wieder."
"Lass es einfach ruhen."
Derjenige, über den
die Geschichte geschrieben wird,
ist völlig machtlos.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Würden Sie sich denn
als sensiblen Menschen bezeichnen?
Ja ...
Sich selbst zu beschreiben,
ist ziemlich schwierig.
Ja, ich ...
Nein, ich weiss es nicht.
Ja, vielleicht schon.
Ja, vielleicht eher sensibel.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Beat sei sogar sehr sensibel,
findet seine Frau.
Die vielen Tiefschläge,
die hinter den beiden liegen,
haben Spuren hinterlassen -
v.a. bei ihm, sagt sie.
Er zeigt es nicht gerne.
- Wieso wohl?
Sehr wahrscheinlich
wurde von ihm immer Stärke verlangt.
Früher hiess es ja immer:
"Jungs weinen nicht.
Das gibt es nicht."
Ich glaube, er stammt
noch aus dieser Generation.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob seine Mutter das zu ihm sagte,
aber in unserer Kindheit
hörte man das noch oft.
Dann wächst man halt so auf,
wird älter und ist es gewohnt,
dies nicht zu zeigen.
So würde ein Mann ja Schwäche
zeigen, denken diese Leute.
Ich hingegen schätze es,
wenn jemand Gefühle zeigt,
auch wenn es ihm nicht gut geht.
Dann kann man
darüber reden und ihm helfen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
2013 meldete Breu Privatkonkurs an.
Er ist heute schuldenfrei
und will sich erneut in
ein finanzielles Abenteuer stürzen.
Ortstermin
mit der Polizei in St. Gallen.
Auf der Kreuzbleiche
will der Circus Beat Breu
Ende Jahr
für mehrere Wochen gastieren.
Die nötigen Bewilligungen bekäme er.
Nur das Geld fehlt noch,
alles andere ist bereit.
Das müsste die 63 sein.
- Ja.
Also ist es
nicht über dem FI-Schalter.
Das reicht schon.
- Ja.
Tipptopp.
Das ist bestens.
Zweifel habe ich keine.
Ich bin davon überzeugt,
dass wir die letzten 100'000
noch auftreiben können.
Sobald wir eine Zusage haben,
können wir die Starttaste drücken.
Dann dauert es ungefähr drei Monate,
bis wir starten können.
Dass er zuerst in St. Gallen
Halt machen möchte, ist kein Zufall.
Hier ist Breu aufgewachsen:
direkt gegenüber der Kreuzbleiche.
In der Nummer 31 kam ich zur Welt
und in der Nummer 33
wohnten wir später.
Die Zirkusse schlugen ihre Zelte
damals direkt vor seiner Haustür auf
und faszinierten den kleinen Beat.
Welche Träume hatten Sie als Kind?
Wissen Sie das noch?
Ja, eigentlich
wollte ich immer zum Zirkus.
Das wäre mein Ziel gewesen.
Was wollten Sie dort tun?
- Das war mir egal.
Ich wollte einfach nur zum Zirkus.
Die Tätigkeit dort
spielte mir keine Rolle.
Was faszinierte Sie denn am Zirkus?
Mich fasziniert es,
dass ein Zirkus aus dem Nichts
in einem Tag aufgebaut wird
und dass er am anderen Morgen
wieder verschwunden ist.
Auch die Tiere
faszinierten mich schon immer.
Mich fasziniert generell alles,
was mit Zelten zu tun hat.
Darum mochte ich auch Camping.
Im Zelt und nun im Wohnmobil
fühle ich mich wohl.
Es geht also um Sehnsüchte
aus seiner Kindheit - aber nicht nur.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
Breu möchte wieder dorthin,
wo er als Sportler war.
Als er noch bejubelt wurde
und nicht belächelt.
In Arbon,
der Heimat seines Veloklubs,
wurde er nach seinen grossen Siegen
als Held empfangen.
Wir fuhren meist
mit dem Zug hierher.
Wir stiegen eine Station vorher ein
und stiegen
grossartig hier in Arbon aus.
Das erste Mal
wurde ich mit einem Lincoln,
einem amerikanischen Oldtimer,
durch Arbon chauffiert.
Dann gab es ein Fest
in einem Festzelt,
mit dem Stadtpräsidenten
und dem Veloklub.
Das sind schöne Erinnerungen.
- Wie fühlten Sie sich damals?
Wie ein kleiner König,
der durch die Stadt gefahren wird
und dem alle zuwinken.
Das ist etwas Aussergewöhnliches,
das nicht jedem passiert,
und da fühlt man sich schon geehrt.
Beat Breu möchte als Gewinner
in Erinnerung bleiben.
Nicht als Verlierer.
Ich hatte früher schöne Erfolge
und es wäre schön,
mit einer Erfolgsgeschichte
abzuschliessen.
Wir werden alles dran setzen,
dass das geschieht.
* Sanfte Klänge *